so people stopped they had no business
there was a guy digging in the trash is
a quarter bitch there was somebody in
the store to pop his head out like what
a bitch one dudes riding a bike mountain
has been a skirt a bitch this
I need to see what the
bitches
[Music]
unlost wrong with junior
the infection on the Netflix series
disappointed give up the crispy
I wish Chicago
yeah where I was raised mostly uh it's a
big game cultures don't know if you hurt
and growing up man I looked up to like
the wrong kind of people cuz I was just
like one of those guys wanting to fit in
what I thought was cool who I looked up
to was gangsters man gangsters and
parents they were the coolest people to
me man they had like cars and right
with women money they had a coolest
outfits pimps had to limp and I'm like
are they hurting naw nigga that's just
swagger
you know mean and it was cool to meet me
I saw looked up to that my big cousin he
was like the head of some gangsters in
this and it was so cool to watch him do
and I was like I want to be down
with that and I like - fighting - I love
to watch fighting buddy know how I've
never been in a fight the most I had
ever done at this point was be in the
mirror like if that fist come up like no
he's just stupid cuz you don't know how
fast fists move this move fast I don't
know if anybody has ever been hit but it
moves fast and then another one comes
right after like it's crazy but I'm this
my stories about how I lost my first two
fights trying to be down and I remember
it like it was yesterday because you
know we all remember the things that
depresses the most I'm with my cousin's
they parked their cars outside it walked
up to my house and they were like yo
Chris you want to walk to the corner
store with us and my cousin real thugs
six five tattoos all over the place
tattoo tear on his face he's not a
killer just a crier but the nigga it's
real you know and he was hanging out
with so many gangsters like six other
dudes and they were all cases that
everybody knew and they wanted me to
walk to destroy them and I'm like oh
yeah dawg don't walk and I was so
excited and terrified because these were
dangerous people and I don't know if
you've walked somewhere with somebody
you scared up but you don't walk like a
normal person I know it's one foot in
front of the other I know how walking
works
were you around somebody carrying a
pistol bigger than your head you start
thinking about some walking the
streets like 1 & 2 & 1
you suck though I'm saying what's up to
people I don't know my cousin's smacking
my head now stop speaking the people
don't know nigga what's wrong with you
and then his friend was like kill what's
wrong with y'all cause he thought he
retarded so I finally got cooler I
finally got comfortable it was a long
long walk so I'm fine like oh man
welcome with the coolest guys in the
neighborhood man I'm on my quest to be a
gangster just right I was on a quest to
be a gangster that's when I wanted to be
and then as right before we get to the
corner store right
this guy he's about 20 years old 14 at
the time he walks right into me full
shoulder POW right in the middle of my
chest boom hit me right and I knew he
did it on purpose but I have two parents
I was raised right so initially I wanna
be like excuse me but I
I felt like this was the right
environment for manners mother
so I didn't say that but what I didn't
say was which is not better I was like a
weak-ass James Brown and that sound was
very loud the guy was confused and he
thought I had said something so he
turned around he said what the hell you
say bitch now we're outside on the south
side of Chicago there's a bunch of
people all around and when somebody says
his bitch like that and in the hood
everyone stops to see who the bitches
you know because and so people stopped
they had no business there was a guy
digging in the trash is a quarter bitch
there was somebody in the store to pop
his head out like what a bitch one dudes
riding the bike money has been a scarred
who the bitch I need to see what the
bitches
my cousin's they were not fazed at all
they just looked at me because all of
those gangsters knew they weren't the
bitch and I was like holy I've
never talked to somebody in front
of people before in public this is my
first time dealing with this so I was
like that is not my name that is not the
way to talk to a grown dang sure with an
alligator tattooed on his face I said
that as if I was going to pull out
my ID like look my name is Christopher
Tyrell red and ain't no bitch in there
so I could tell it wasn't the right way
to respond to this man by his face he
was confused he was like the the
alligator on his face was confused with
him he slapped my hand right cuz I was
pointing at him and he smacked my hand
now I what I wanted to do is but nothing
you know since I want to do something
cool but what came out was I bet it hurt
what she did and you can visually tell
it hurt because my face said oh and he
was like you never mind all this
man what the you up and then I was
like oh no no
no I say that in my head I like nah but
I realize haven't spoken yet and my
cousin was like dog you gotta prove
yourself for all these gangsters so I
knew I had to say something right so I
was like ah that is not the outcome
which is that's not how you respond to
people I said that's it like I had some
type of bar grab behind me if you look
here this is you this is me this is the
outcome and they're very different class
dismissed
I knew it wasn't enough cuz my cousin
was looking at me like what the is
wrong with you he didn't say that but
his eyes said it his eyes like so I knew
I had to follow it up so I was like you
know what I'm not good at this
how much just say what he's saying cuz
it sounded real good and so I was like
no I'm a you and before I could say
up
he hit me directly in my throat like
direct it was a direct line to my throat
my Adam's apple checked out nigga I
don't know if you've been hitting
directly your throat but a couple of
things happen put one your throat says
and it just closed forever your
spit is like it's suicide I was like I
don't need to be in the mouth dog hey I
got hit so hard in my throat that I had
a limp and that is not how science works
I like Oh nigga I'm a pimp now I'm a
halfway to my goal
it made no sense and I farted a little
bit I did yo I've never been hit so hard
I I may be but my thought was
closed so there had to go somewhere it
was very embarrassing man but what was
more embarrassing is this was outside
man so people from across the street saw
a very different fight than the fight
that went down you know me like yo yo
dawg what happened over there bro that
was crazy over there what happened guys
let me tell you so so the bigger dude
was like I'm gonna you up right and
for whatever reason the little dude was
like imma you
like why would you say that so the
bigger dude hit him in the throat save
his asshole for another day you know and
that was the story that went around the
hood for like six months at least and I
like that's not how it went down
my cousin was very embarrassed he had a
reputation to maintain and I got my ass
whipped before the whole hood he grabbed
me and took me home under my arm there's
no way to keep your masculinity with you
being grabbed under your arm by a grown
man all right let me go he's like making
me I'm like you know I can't you know so
he threw me in the house you know I mean
he was like Chris said he's got damn
streets it's ain't for you duh all
right go to school be somebody this
ain't for you you got hit directly in yo
broke nigga and you forty in front
and I was like yo keep it down nigga
everybody saw
and then he closed the door and I was
like no I gotta avenge myself but he was
gone already and usually you know when
something like that happens you're like
you know what this isn't for me he's
right i'ma go I'm gonna go do something
else but I was a hard-headed kid with
goals and I was like you know what I'm
gonna learn how to fight I'm gonna
redeem myself this is what I want to do
so the whole year until they asked me to
fight again I was practicing I was
fighting friends we could just be boxing
wrestling in the yard and give my
hands up
I would watch Bruce Lee because I didn't
know what a boxing class was yet Bruce
Lee was the baddest go
around you watch these tapes he was
beating 15 people at the same time
people waiting in line they get their
ass whooped by Bruce Lee hell's a hell
yeah I want to be that good I would
practice all his moves and I was like yo
whenever I get in a fight again I'm
gonna be ready and it was a year later
when my cousin asked me to come fight
with them right he was like yo I heard
from a couple people man that you got
some hands now you've been in some
fights listen we got a hand of some
man me and some other dudes you want to
ride with us I was like hell yeah man
cuz I gotta redeem myself and my cousin
was like don't ever say that again
nikka you are not a coupon and he was
right I'm not a coupon I'm he's very
right about that so I jumped in the
truck and it was me my cousin and the
five of the dudes that was with us when
I got my ass whipped the first time so
most the conversation was about how I
got my ass whooped
the first up which sucks cuz this bitch
ass think I'm I'm right here and I have
a name at one point I was like hey uh
this isn't good for morale and they
didn't know it and they didn't know what
morale man they thought it was a chick
that wasn't giving me no so then
they started talking about that for
ten minutes like I'm around like giving
this thing up
I'm like man I wish I didn't drop out of
eighth grade but I just let it happen
but nothing I could do
and I'm Chicago we should fight these
like old lots or he's old fields so that
police wouldn't lock you up for you know
extended amounts of time like they do
black people in America so we could
fight and go home and you know it's
before like shooting well there's still
shooting but these guys would fight it
out right and so he rolled up to this
field it's my first time being in this
field of right and I'm looking
around as I get into car and the Sun is
said there's flowers I'm like the oldest
a romantic place to get so extra why why
are we fighting in the are Kelly said I
don't want to get knocked out and fall
in love nigga I didn't say this is all
in my head oh I wasn't saying nothing I
learned from the mistakes I was like I'm
not gonna sue not gonna say no I'm gonna
be tough to hold time so I was grab my
dick wait longer than that he's
walking around like it was good and at
one point the gang she was like yeah
what's wrong with total dick nothing
Nicola
I studied he was like you got to make
sure was there my shut the up
so anyway this it's me and six of the
dudes right now two cars pull up right
to 4-door sedans there was 20 dudes in
these two four-door sedans and I don't
know if y'all do math quick but 20 goos
cannot fit comfortably in two four-door
sedans that meant that these gangsters
rolled to this gang fight lapped up
which it's not a gangster way to travel
that means that y'all were right like yo
we gonna them up you know what I'm
saying
you know what I'm saying and it goes
like yeah yeah because you lift your
buck because you picked up why are you
working on me cuz so when they do is
gonna have one more car
by say nothing and they pull it up 20
dudes clown card out the cars
and they stretch them on this field the
Sun was behind them and for a split
second I was like are these niggers the
heroes because they look like the heroes
of the story Brian say nothing man and
as they walk towards this everybody
who's doing it whatever they do I was
sitting there holding my dick I think I
was on him with two hands which is so
weird don't kick me here you know then
the guy in the middle he was like hey
man hey yo we bought the y'all and
before he could say up I was like not
again I read which had to be weird for
the guys hear me say not again
who does that ever like not again
but I ran so fast everybody was shot
like where's he going
you know me they they all had questions
I ran up to the guy in the middle I
jumped and I realized he's very tall so
I had that's why I had to bring it up
here bad when I swung and I hit and I
connected to his chin right now hitting
somebody when he don't deserve it it's
the asshole thing to do but when you
have somebody that's trying to kill you
oh it feels great and I'm like Oh
fireworks went off of my head it was
amazing I was like I'm the king of
everything I saw his spit fly like I
know what that's like you know it was a
solid punch man you know it was great
and I celebrate I'm like yeah I'm
finally a gangster in my mind I'm saying
this and as I'm saying this for fish hit
me at the same time I don't know if
you've been hitting unison but the
hurts a lot one felt like it came from
God like you sure did and as I got hit
at the same time I yelled out y'all
supposed to wait like Bruce Lee like
yeah yo that dumb out yeah
and I fell to the ground I think I
knocked out for about 30-40 seconds
right I came to my face hurting
pulsating everywhere but I looked around
and I noticed that nobody was fighting
because everybody was laughing at what
the I just said these grow legs
just holding gun
yo there there reenacting what just
happened like whoever
have you ever seen a good conversation
and you try to laugh your way into it
that's what I did was right that was
crazy honey they pushed me away like
shut your bitch ass up and after ten
minutes of them laughing at me pointing
laughing re-enacting and laughing the
gangster from the other gang was like
you know what uh mood out that was that
was funny as hell
hey you know what I forgot what the
we was fighting about hey let's go to
McDonald dancing fool go get some drinks
man just chill and let's talk about your
cousin some more nigga and all I'm
saying is I'm bringing communities
together so what the are y'all
doing
[Applause]
Oh